I was reading that you first came across
this project and brought its universal
back in 2010 obviously performance
capture has come a long long way since
then so how does what you were picturing
for this story back then differ from
what we got today well 15 years have
gone by since the first performance
capture movie ever done which was Polar
Express to now so in the digital realm
that's like a hundred years of advanced
technology so you know we have the tools
now to do it in a I would say very close
to flawless way what were some of your
earlier tests like because I also read
that there was a point where you maybe
just considered having your actors wear
the costumes to make them look like the
dolls yeah we consider we considered
everything you thought you know you know
have them where you'll put like you know
plastic makeup on them and give them
costumes that had arm joints and things
like that and and build live you know
live scale miniatures that they could
live in but at the end of the day turned
out that you know we have these digital
tools we have the digital cinema and
performance capture or advanced
performance capture was the way to go
being one of the people in this industry
who have worked with performance capture
so so heavily I'm wondering your opinion
on this when are we gonna have a
performance caption performance that we
are judging right alongside a
live-action performance especially in
the midst of award season right now
probably in about five years it's bound
to happen soon and I'm rooting for it
can you tell me a little bit about
working with your cast here because you
have a number of people if not all of
your main cast who are doing performance
capture for the very first time so what
is I guess pointer number one or
performance capture 101 so you can ease
them into it well performance capture
101 is is that they gotta get over the
fact that they don't get to wear a
costume and they have to wear there's a
horrible leotard onesie type suit but
once they get over that then they
actually love the process because it's
like doing black box theater it's all
about performance and all we do all day
is perform talked about performance
and they get to act all day long and
they don't have to worry about all this
technology and lighting and hit you know
hitting their marks and all that stuff
that you have to worry about when you're
making a you know a normal movie do you
have more room to play in that realm of
this movie compared to the live-action
stuff because I was watching some of the
b-roll and you're giving such specific
direction that I imagine is just
necessary when you're combining these
two styles yeah you know you have to be
aware of everything but yeah I mean I
hope I'm not giving too much direction
but I mean I have to well we have
certain limitations and certain things
that we have to keep you know within the
rep you know within the realm of what
we're doing but you know when you're
working with great actors they can make
anything work for you now
Mark's story is very very specific but
this whole idea of kind of healing
healing through art and having an
emotional healing process is really
Universal idea so I was curious what do
you do when you need to center yourself
do you have a hobby or a craft beyond
filmmaking that you kind of turn to well
I actually do have a hobby I fly III fly
airplanes that's I don't know if that's
a healing thing but it keeps you in the
moment let me put it that way
you